all right dino
yes you know where'd you grow up where
are you from originally i'm originally
from san diego
san diego and tell me about your family
you had both your parents i had both my
parents in my life um
my mother i stayed with my mother most
of the time and my dad was in and out
and um there's six of us three boys and
three girls
and i'm the oldest of the boys so how
would you describe your childhood
my childhood um as the typical black
person's childhood you know
trials and tribulations mother and dad
fighting
domestic violence police being called
trying to protect my mom and
trying to you know hustle every day to
provide for the family
and how about you in school i did
excellent at school i went to hoover
high graduated with a 3.58 epa
uh went to college too for two years
yeah
and how did you get into the game i got
in the game
at a young age um i think i was around
13
i had um a pimp pulled up on me and said
hey
i want you to serve my hoe i said serve
your hoe
what does that mean he sent a coach
card to come pick me up and it was a
lincoln
i said okay car came and got me a driver
went to the hotel it's like yeah i need
you to serve this
serve this chick what part of the game
is this he's like i'm going to pay you
for your time
the server so basically he wanted me to
go ahead and break his [ __ ]
his main [ __ ] that i've been having
eyes on and from there i broke the [ __ ]
he paid me and she was my [ __ ] and it's
been
going ever since so your job was to
break a [ __ ] and break means what [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out of them
break that hoe down break the [ __ ]
so i mean tell me what the the basic
basically i guess she was out of pocket
some way shape form or fashion
and this is punishment punishment
basically what it was why he sat there
and got high
why i [ __ ] his main [ __ ] and he paid
me to do it
i thought that was excellent
i mean a lot of the relationship between
a pimp and a prostitute seems to be
almost like mind control you're
absolutely right
once you get ahold of their mind you
know we're there's security
they feel secure with us you know we
provide things that they're lacking of
or that
they didn't have growing up
is it it also seems to me this is just
my guess
that a lot of these women came from
abusive
uh childhoods where they're they were
molested as
you know sexual abuse or physical abuse
or dad was out of the picture
some some form of dysfunction in their
childhood so now as an adult they find
this lifestyle provides a similar
comfort it's what they're used to yeah
absolutely right so you get these
these these guys they're just using you
right right and then you get these pimps
that are taking advantage of you and
using you
and that is what you're used to you're
right it's sad but
it is but it's life you know we're we're
dealt cards of
in life is it's like playing cards you
build a delta hand
and it's up to you to make a choice but
it's you know so many people want to
blame the pimp so you're taking
advantage of these girls
and what i'm hearing over and over again
they choose
us the women are choosing these guys
absolutely right treat them the way they
absolutely right they treat it and you
give them a way out man they don't want
it they don't want it
you're absolutely right i said you want
to go to school what do you want to do
you want to
you know get a career do something
different they say no
they say no and they might complain that
they can't get out and they you know
they're they're not saving money and all
that but
you don't see them making the serious
effort to get out no you don't
you don't what i see it's a serious
effort to bring daddy money
that's what it is bring bring me my
money yeah so your arrangement is they
bring you how much of the money
um it depends you know
a thousand only three girls working
but so they're not bringing you hundred
percent of course
they better bring me a hundred percent
i'm going to give them um a half fifty
percent of them
100 percent of pep in our of pepper oh i
see so they do bring
yeah they gotta bring a hundred percent
to the table and what do they get out of
that
they get stability they get a roof over
their head they get clothes
they get money for their pockets if they
wanna go get their nails done feet done
is there some form of protection that
you provide too of course at all times
and how do you how do you do that either
i'm if they're uncomfortable with the
trick they give me a call
i'm outside the room you know we have
little codes
we use and i'm in the room within 15
seconds
i'm in the dough you know i'm in that
dough
it's a it's a dangerous life for the
girls right it is a dangerous life but
it's also
yeah yeah it is because ain't no telling
every car they jump in
you don't know if this is the last time
you're going to see them or what's the
tricks on what's on the trick's mind or
what he what he could do
it's a crazy life it is it's a really
crazy lifestyle because
as an outside as a square right i hear
the girls tell you stories like
you're just getting you're risking your
life every night right
you're getting beaten up regularly right
you're giving away
a lot of your money if not all right
you're right
you're not saving you're right so
you just shake your heads ahead and go
man right
and they can't see it they can't see a
way out has to do with
psychology you know psychological
there's something wrong with the
individual
or that's what they're used to so that's
the comfort zone and that's what they
want to continue to happen to them
yeah it's like that's that's what they
want that's exactly what they want
because you give them something better
and they yes yes they don't know what to
do with it
you're absolutely right so learn
learning this
was this a natural thing for you or you
learned it as young man um
i don't know i used to sell lollipops at
school so suckers 25 cent suckers and
the
um bubblicious bubble gum 50 cents a
pack
and i'll always have my way with the
with the ladies you know right now i got
a wife
a girlfriend a mistress and a side [ __ ]
on the side
but they all know about each other
either you're going to get with the
program or you're not
you know you're honest with everybody
i got to be i got to be today it'd be
too stressful to kind of
man yeah
you've been arrested for this i've never
been arrested for this um
i'm in in the fast money you know san
diego
tijuana's right there so anything i want
i'll go get
so you work out of san diego or l.a i'm
i'm from san diego but i live in l.a you
literally know yeah
and your girls are different races yeah
what what do you have caucasian snow
bunnies
is the go-getters they don't come with
as much problems you know
they go out get the money they bring
bring me the money and everything is
everything so fewer headaches with white
girls a few
headaches you get so many stories
there's too many problems behind the
money you know
it doesn't add up you know you're out
there for five hours you only got a
hundred dollars
the other one's out there for two hours
she got a thousand dollars like what's
going on
and why so white girls bring in more
money yeah yeah
it's a higher market out there and then
as far as the
the customers the clients do the girls
steer away from certain races
they try to stay away from african
americans
meaning some of them say their dick is
too big and
they're just too much uh aggressive um
you know i hear a lot of girls saying
they're always playing games they're
always right right they're trying to say
they got the money but they ain't got
money
right right
is sex part of the scene with your girls
sometimes you know they get if they do
good
they get treated good you know
when you sex with a prostitute is
different because
a pimp could go as far as you want up in
a [ __ ]
but a trick she's only gonna let him go
so far so
you know pleasure is for the pimp but
it's it's just
this is life this is weird [ __ ] it's
really really weird
you ever been left yeah i have
um to my second baby mama
um 14 years three beautiful kids um
i was i was a square i was a nine to
five working off of wilshire boulevard
working on slauson and and western
you know nine to five and seven to
eleven two jobs
like a machine but when you don't get
appreciated at home
or they take your kindness for weakness
then you seek attention
and you you know you build up this
defense
and then you you use it on somebody else
you try to manipulate somebody else and
get what you want
or what you're yearning for what you're
craving for what qualities do you look
for in a girl
qualities i look for in a grill is
somebody who's smart
you know good looking doesn't
necessarily have to play a big factor
you know she could be at 500 pounds you
know but
she has a sweet personality um
you know lips is a plus and the face the
face got to be a1
because if the body's not all together
long enough the face is together then
she got some potential
and what happens when like your girls
get out of line do you ever have to
i'm not abusive i've seen that growing
up too much
in the streets and in the game um
punishment somewhat but it's
nothing drastic and i never slap a [ __ ]
you know
how about drugs i don't do them girls
they don't need to don't if they don't
they don't they don't let me know
it seems like just to do this you would
need to be drunk or high
you're absolutely right and to get that
fix and get that motivation or that
courage or that strength to go out there
and go do it you're right
i have a hard time imagining a girl can
just do this straight without
right some kind of chemical without
getting depressed or something like that
you're right
what's more important you love our money
that's a good ass question you know
money
is more important than love right now
because without money you have nothing
you can't do nothing
what personality trait helps you you
know excel at this
charisma my gift of gab just to be able
to speak to somebody talk to somebody
and break them down or
oh make them feel comfortable with me
attraction's a big part of it for the
thing
of course that she has to be attracted
to of course of course
and what's the craziest thing you've
seen the craziest thing i've seen
was a prostitute
getting shot by a trick with a 357 shot
her in the ass
and i don't know maybe she was in his
pockets or something happened something
happened in the car
before i know he pulled out a gun and
she was bent over and he shot her in the
ass
so that's about it
stealing from the tricks is part of the
game part of the game yeah
catching with his pants down to his
ankles you know she's in the pockets and
the money goes
you know is this weird it's weird it's
[ __ ] crazy
it's a weird little world because
everybody's out
for their own best interest right you're
absolutely right
yeah everybody everybody everybody
that's what it is
exactly what it is how many kids do you
have i got four
how would you feel funny you have
daughters i got two daughters i got a 18
year old
and a 13 year old how would you feel if
you saw the 18 year old on the blade one
day
you know what um it's funny that you
said that because
my oldest daughter she's wild now like i
met her
mom off the party line i hit it one time
nine much later she called me told me
the baby was mine
so everything that she's doing i don't
agree of
of her lifestyle but all i can do is
support her
and have her back that's all i can do
and what's the most important lesson
you've learned
life is about choices okay
you have a choice either to partake
in what's going on in the environment or
you could be a square and just you know
just do right
ain't nothing wrong with doing right i
swear to god if i could go back 10 or 20
years
back and i could go change my life and
do it over again i would
you love the square life yeah the square
life was all right going to encinitas
surfing beach
you know starbucks just doing normal
routine [ __ ]
good [ __ ] living life hiking
better karma yeah
yeah there's a lot of different uh
styles okay to being attempt right yeah
absolutely right
there's gorilla pimps there's there is
yeah there's there's guys that sweet
talk to girls there's so tell me about
that which one of you
i'm suave or casanova you know um
i just make them i break them down make
them feel comfortable then i tell them
what i'm what i'm about you know maybe
they you're going to shoes up or they
ain't but but then all these different
styles
all kind of go into the umbrella of mind
control yeah absolutely
you're right so no matter what your
style you're still like
long enough you control that mind you
got it you got it
and how does that make you feel at night
when you're when you're by yourself
you're going to bed
you're okay with the fact that that's
how you make your living
no but i'm comfortable with it
for the time being until another
opportunity
opens its doors for me then uh i'll
venture off but
right now i'm okay
all right dino thank you so much for
sharing your story hey i appreciate you
i wish you the best of luck all right
thanks a lot thank you
you